[Music]
september 10th
freedom day in denmark
that day the nordic country ditches all
covet curves
fifty thousand danes celebrate the first
post pandemic free concert in copenhagen
[Applause]
i only thought about covet 19 for a
second when i arrived like wow there's a
lot of people here but i've totally
forgotten about it it's just so awesome
to be here
denmark is the first country in europe
to drop all coronavirus restrictions
vaccine passports are no longer needed
to enter bars restaurants or nightclubs
74 of all people are fully vaccinated
and with a very low covet reproduction
rate officials say the virus is now
under control
welcome to your covert 19 special i'm
chris kober in berlin
no longer a socially critical disease
that is the danish government's
assessment of covet 19. after more than
540 days with restrictions to limit the
spread of the coronavirus denmark's high
vaccination rate has enabled citizens to
return to pre-pandemic life at least
inside the
country this is where the man works
whose job it is to explain the pandemic
to the danes virologist alan rundrup
he's convinced that the rapid lockdown
in march 2020 spared the country the
worst
i actually i was in the
studio one of the television channels
the evening that our prime minister
announced that we would have the
complete shutdown of denmark i think it
was the right thing and actually a big
part of the reason
why we have
have had such a relatively mild cause
compared to others
now the government has announced that
covet 19 no longer poses a national
threat and suddenly the corona passes
and masks have vanished from denmark's
streets
the main reason for this radical opening
is the high vaccination rate among
citizens and the authorities detailed
information campaign and all measures
taken
among the most vulnerable of our
patients and citizens the vaccination
rate is more than 9 out of 10. and the
general population is more than 8 out of
10. one thing that we
i think we did very good here and that
people might learn from is the
transparency of the effort but it might
also be the culture that that when the
danish healthcare authorities recommend
something usually the danish people do
it german's vaccination rate is quite a
bit lower as a citizens trust in the
authorities
would make a complete opening such as in
denmark less advisable
now throngs of joyful danes are headed
back to amusement parks
many of them are pleased with the
government's handling of the crisis i
believe that they've handled it from
the intention of doing it best possible
so i think
on the whole i think they've done well
[Applause]
covert testing continues
some experts propose monitoring waste
water to localize future outbreaks while
germans might balk at this kind of
surveillance the danish state is already
highly digitalized making it better
equipped to respond to the pandemic
we have a register of everybody who
tests positive in a laboratory with the
disease we also have a register of who's
vaccinated and we have regis a
population register so we know where
everybody lives and we can contact
people directly when i talk to
colleagues in other countries i can
really see that that has given us an
edge that is a particular thing of
denmark which have helped us
but these days many ordinary danes are
diving headlong back into the lifestyles
they were living before
and hoping they finally got uncovered
under control
let's talk about how the danes did it
with camilla holten-muller she is a
medical doctor and head of the expert
group for mathematical modeling of
covid19 at denmark's stanton's serum
institute welcome to dw camilla for the
moment the pandemic seems to be under
control what are the key elements that
denmark apparently got right in order to
get to this point
i think very importantly in the
springtime we had a really large test
capacity we did a massive test screening
both in schools and in
workplaces
which allowed us simply to to track the
the infected persons very
locally and we had some local lockdowns
that also worked very effectively which
we were able to do simply because of
this
screening test or test strategy we had
in denmark
there seems to be a predominant feeling
of trust
among the danish public trust when it
comes to authorities
and the way they've been handling the
pandemic where the distrust stem from
i think historically uh the danes in
general have a very high trust in in the
health authorities and also in in the
other vaccination campaigns for instance
vaccination of children there's a very
high trust and support of the program
and i think that really also helps us in
the current situation with covet
in many places people are skeptical when
it comes to getting vaccinated against
the coronavirus now looking at denmark's
high vaccination rate which is one of
the highest in the world things appear
to be different
somewhat
why is that
i think first of all is definitely
related to the high trust both in health
authorities but also in general to to to
vaccination programs and vaccinations in
general but i think we had some really
nice campaigns here in denmark and
really informing very nicely about the
the vaccines and and a lot of
transparency and also that this is a
free choice to get vaccinated i think
that has helped us a lot
and camilla particularly young people
now among them the vaccination rate is
lower than the total average
if they can now go back to clubs and
bars without any restrictions could they
become the new drivers of this pandemic
well i take it that no doubt about it
that the unvaccinated will definitely be
a driver of the the epidemic
and especially also children who are not
to be vaccinated children below 12
um amongst the young ones especially is
their way of behaving of course going to
clubs and bars where they're really
close together but definitely that will
be an issue and of course we try to
strive towards having the highest
vaccination coverage as possible in
those groups as well
does denmark specifically target these
people who are eligible for a
vaccination but have chosen not to get
the job so far
yes there is definitely a large campaign
going on so first of all making a
vaccination available
we have vaccinations in high schools we
have vaccinations in supermarkets so
vaccination is
really available everywhere you have
drop-in vaccination but of course also
campaigns on social media which is also
important to to reach out to these
groups
now more than
around three quarters of the danish
population are fully vaccinated what
does that mean
going into the fall and going into the
winter where infections rose in the past
i think what is really important in that
story is as well is that we have a very
high vaccination coverage especially in
the risk groups and in old people who
are at risk of having a severe covet
situation a covet infection that is
really important and of course it's also
important that we just in general have a
high coverage in and above 50 years old
as well
um
that that is the main
goal
camilla having regained their freedom
would the danes go back into lockdown if
infections spiked again
of course i think they would if it
became necessary but i don't think it
will become necessary i mean we have a
really good experience that we can do
well with local lockdowns and also we
have proven that this really a large
test system allows us to to do more
uh local lockdowns instead of these
large national lockdowns i think we will
go
further with that and that will
hopefully be successful in case it
should be needed
carmilla holden miller of the staten
serum institute in copenhagen coming up
thank you for talking to us
now while the danes may be further ahead
than others on their way out of the
pandemic there is the issue of how much
longer we are going to have to deal with
this here is our science correspondent
derek williams answering one of your
questions
how long do most pandemics last
to make any predictions about how the
covet 19 pandemic could end
it makes sense
to look at past pandemics and since they
provide data that could potentially help
us predict
how long the current one might last
experts trying to do that
tend to focus on the four officially
recognized respiratory disease pandemics
that have occurred in the last hundred
years which were all driven by an old
enemy of humanity um influenza
the most recent one was in 2009 when a
novel flu strain commonly called the
swine flu
swept the globe infecting by some
estimates up to one in five people on
the planet uh top end guesses say it
might have caused close to six hundred
thousand deaths
in the 14 or so months that that it
raged the swine flu pandemic was shorter
than a flu pandemic in in 1968 often
called um the hong kong flu
it was caused by a strain that killed at
least a million people worldwide
possibly many more
all in all it lasted a little less than
two years
a decade before that a strain that
became widely known as the asian flu
killed a similar number of people in in
the late 1950s now what was really
interesting about that pandemic
was that it was the first where vaccines
played a key role it's thought that
their quick development and distribution
saved potentially hundreds of thousands
of lives
finally
there was the granddaddy of all modern
flu pandemics the one that devastated
the planet at the end of the first world
war um starting in around 1918.
it's viewed
as the most severe pandemic in recent
history that flu strain infected we
think around a third of the world's
population
and killed at least 50 million people
over the course of around
three years so
to sum it up
those recent pandemics lasted between
around a year and and three years but
they were of course
caused by flu viruses not coronaviruses
so
so trying to draw parallels with the
current pandemic experts say
that is a tenuous move at best
[Music]
and that's our show for more check out
our website at dw.com
kovit19 for now thanks for watching stay
safe
[Music]